it's different in some ways in the same
in other ways so so I worked after I got
my PhD I worked at Bell Labs as sort of
an industrial but really basic research
place for six years and was working on
technologies that ultimately led to this
prize but I got fed up with the
limitations at the time and I quit
science and then worked in my father's
machine tool company which is a much
smaller enterprise a few hundred guys
but you know although in the academic
world oftentimes I think they looked
down their noses at what happens in
industry it's been my experience that
many of the people I met working in my
father's company were as smart if not
smarter than many of my colleagues I've
had an academia people are just smart in
different ways in different fields and
they peek at different times you know
oftentimes guys in industry you know or
later bloomers and the sort of young
kids who latch on to science early but
it's all about problem solving you know
in in either endeavor and clever people
find ways to solve problems in all walks
of life my father is now retired he's 90
so so but I worked with him up until
let's see until he was about 80 years
old so yeah